¿Se le puede parar los pies a China?
¿Cómo hacer que Xi Jinping detenga de una
vez por todas su política de confrontación
con los países democráticos?
¿Cómo diantres podemos evitar que el régimen
totalitario de Pekín se convierta en un riesgo
y una amenaza para todos?
Queridos amigos, amigas, hoy más que nunca
estas preguntas están de máxima actualidad.
(China ha experimentado un enorme cambio.
Tras décadas de rápido crecimiento y modernización
tecnológica, productiva y militar, ahora
el régimen de Xi Jinping está obsesionado
con una idea: convertir a China en el nuevo
hegemón mundial.
La nueva superpotencia capaz de rivalizar
con los Estados Unidos.
Quieren acabar con la hegemonía de Occidente
para lograr que Pekín se convierta en la
nueva capital de referencia internacional.)
Precisamente por eso, bajo el gobierno del
Partido Comunista, China está tratando de
incrementar su influencia política, económica,
militar y, hasta, cultural.
¿El problema?
Qué China sigue siendo una dictadura totalitaria.
Y eso debería preocuparnos a todos.
Sobre todo cuándo Xi Jinping está desarrollando
una agenda cada vez más hostil.
¿Queréis algunos ejemplos?
Pues veamos, estoy totalmente seguro de que
la inmensa mayoría de vosotros habéis oído
hablar del famoso globo Chino que sobrevoló
Estados Unidos, que fue descubierto mientras
sobrevolaba una instalación de misiles balísticos
nucleares en Montana y que, finalmente fue
destruido por un F22.
Un globo que, según parece, portaba antenas
y sensores para recopilar inteligencia e interceptar
comunicaciones.
De hecho, según ha confirmado el Deportado
de Estados norteamericano el propio fabricante
del globo tiene una relación directa con
el ejército chino.
(EL globo chino llevaba antenas y otros equipos
para recabar información, según EE.UU.
Segun un funcionario, Estados Unidos se prepara
para tomar medidas contra entidades vinculadas
al programa chino de vigilancia de globos.
WSJ)
Y para colmo hemos sabido que no se trata
de un caso aislado.
Ahora sabemos que podemos encontrar muchos
más casos.
Al parecer se trata de una flota de globos
y aparatos supuestamente espías que operan
en los cinco continentes….
Incluyendo, ya lo veis, Estados Unidos…
Lo que supone una clara preocupación.
Claro que los globos no son lo más peligroso
ni provocador del espionaje chino.
Los ciberataques son mucho peores…
¿Y sabéis qué?
Llevan años siendo tan frecuentes que el
propio director del FBI James Comey bromeó
en 2014 diciendo “Hay dos tipos de grandes
empresas en los Estados Unidos: las que han
sido hackeadas por los chinos y las que no
saben que han sido hackeadas por los chinos”.
Los ciberespías chinos han atacado sistemáticamente
a los Estados Unidos robándole al gobierno
y a las empresas norteamericanas, planos,
diseños industriales, secretos comerciales
y todo tipo de información confidencial..
Incluso se han hecho con material clasificado
de proyectos tan importantes como el F-35.
Lo que evidentemente, como os podéis imaginar,
no hace ninguna gracia en Washington.
¿Os acordáis de cuándo el gobierno de Estados
Unidos dejó de comprar dispositivos de Huawei
y pidió a las empresas norteamericanas que
no usaran sus productos?
Pues… este fue exactamente el motivo.
Ahora bien, el creciente choque entre China,
Estados Unidos y la comunidad de las democracias
liberales va mucho más allá del espionaje.
La agenda de confrontación de Pekín también
está detrás de noticias como esta:
N2 (China ayuda a la guerra de Rusia en Ucrania,
según muestran los datos comerciales.
A pesar de las sanciones, Moscú equipa a
sus cazas a reacción, submarinos y soldados
con la ayuda de compañías chinas.
WSJ)
China no sólo no ha secundado las sanciones
sino que como gesto está enviando a Rusia,
entre otros componentes, equipos de navegación
para los helicópteros M-17 de Rusia, equipos
de interferencia de comunicaciones y piezas
que pueden ser utilizadas en los cazas Todo
eso sí en cantidades no muy grandes.
¿Y por qué decimos que esto es una especie
de provocación?
Pues, porque, y ojo que esto es lo más interesante,
no se trata de envíos masivos.
Si China quisiera podría suministrarle a
Rusia grandes cantidades de armamento…
Si quisiera.
Pero como ya os dimos aquí en VisualPolitik
no parece que quieran y arriesgarse con ello
a un choque masivo con Occidente.
Así que lo que parece que están haciendo
es enviar equipos que les permita quedar bien
con Moscú al tiempo que marcan su distancia
con Estados Unidos, la Unión Europea y el
resto de países aliados de estos.
Para ello envían sobre todo equipos de doble
uso, es decir, que pueden ser utilizados tanto
para fines militares como civiles.
Pero sea como sea, esto está ayudando a Rusia
y es un gesto, además, que deja muy pero
que muy claro que mañana su posición podría
cambiar.
En cualquier caso es otro gesto desafiante
más.
Y no, aún no hemos terminado.
(Luego tenemos lo ocurrido con Hong Kong y,
sobre todo, las constantes amenazas sobre
Taiwán.
Amenazas que se han multiplicado en los últimos
años y que han hecho, incluso, que altos
oficiales del ejército de Estados Unidos
estén alertando de que la invasión de la
isla podría producirse mucho antes de lo
que cualquier hubiera podido imaginar.)
Globos espías, ciberataques, colaboración
con Rusia, ocupación de Hong Kong y las amenazas
constantes a Taiwán.
Y también a otros muchos países como Lituania.
El resultado es que la agenda de Xi Jinping
le ha dado a China una política exterior
mucho más activa y hostil con lo que podríamos
denominar el mundo libre.
Y la pregunta es, ¿qué demonios se puede
hacer para frenar a Pekín?
¿Qué medidas podría tomar Estados Unidos
para castigar o evitar este tipo de situaciones?
No es una pregunta menor...
Es una de las preguntas más importantes de
nuestro tiempo.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Justo aquí surge la hipótesis de las sanciones.
¿Puede frenarse la agenda imperialista de
Xi Jinpin con sanciones económicas?
¿Es esta la mejor forma de enfrentarse al
gigante asiático?
En este vídeo vamos a responder a estas preguntas.
Pero lo primero de todo es saber de qué hablamos
exactamente.
Atentos.
T1 (EL CASTIGO ECONÓMICO)
¿Son útiles y eficaces las sanciones económicas?
¿Realmente sirven para algo?
Ojo que este no es un debate precisamente
nuevo, existe desde por lo menos hace 2.500
años.
De hecho,una de los primeros paquetes de sanciones
económicas de los que se tienen constancia
es el conocido como Decreto de Megara en el
año 432 a.c.
Fijaos si ha llovido.
Con este decreto Atenas prohibió el comercio
con Megara y prohibió a los comerciantes
de esta última ciudad el acceso a los puertos
atenienses….
Lo que para muchos fue la causa principal
que alimentó la Guerra del Peloponeso.
(Mucho más recientemente la Sociedad de Naciones
sancionó, por ejemplo, a Italia en 1935 por
la invasión de la región etiope de Abisinia.
Pocos años después Estados Unidos hizo lo
propio con el Imperio de Japón y con Alemania
del III Reich.
Pero sobre todo las sanciones empezaron a
cobrar más y más peso a partir de los años
50 y sobre todo se multiplicaron tras los
atentados del 11 de septiembre.
Desde la Sudáfrica del Apartheid, al Irán
de los Ayatolás pasando por el ISIS, la Corea
de Kim Jong Un, el régimen de Gadafi o, incluso,
el Cartel de Cali.)
En este gráfico podéis ver bien claro como
los castigos económicos se han hecho cada
vez más y más populares.
Por supuesto - y seguro que no os sorprendo
a ninguno - estos castigos económicos han
sido liderados por Estados Unidos aprovechando
el peso mundial que tiene tanto el dólar
como su sistema financiero.
Este es el gráfico que aglutina las sanciones
de Estados Unidos contra países, empresas
e individuos de todos los rincones del planeta.
Fijaos cómo ha evolucionado en los últimos
20 años.
Y si incluyamos 2022 el gráfico se dispararía
muchísimo.
Porque, por supuesto, como todos, absolutamente
todos sabéis, el último gran programa de
sanciones masivas es, precisamente, el que
tiene que ver con la Rusia de Putin tras la
invasión de Ucrania.
Ahora bien, la pregunta es, ¿funcionan?
Pues…
Depende de como se mire.
En un pasado vídeo, aquí en VisualPolitik,
ya os mostramos como las sanciones a Rusia
estaban consiguiendo logros muy importantes…
Aunque tengamos la sensación de que no han
conseguido tumbar la economía rusa.
De hecho, para evitar daños importantes en
la economía mundial las sanciones suelen
dirigirse a campos muy concretos.
Es decir, que casi pueden verse como ataques
quirúrgicos.
Esa es, al menos, la tendencia de los últimos
años.
En el caso de Rusia, sin ir más lejos, hablamos
de ataques contra su sistema financiero, los
ingresos del gobierno, su industria tecnológica
y militar y la inversión extranjera.
De esta forma lo que se está haciendo es
intentar causar el mayor daño posible a medio
plazo sin, por ejemplo, reventar el mercado
energético mundial.
Eso es lo que explica que no se haya fijado
un tope al precio del petróleo ruso en lugar
de prohibir todo el comercio con el petróleo
ruso.
Pero…
Un momento…
Porque, a ver, hablar de China y de sanciones
no es como hablar de Rusia, Corea del Norte,
Irán o prácticamente cualquier otro país.
Hablar de China son palabras mayores
Así que la pregunta es…
¿Realmente se puede sancionar a China?
Y de poder, ¿serviría de algo?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2 (¿SE PUEDE SANCIONAR A CHINA?)
Estados Unidos y China se llevan peor que
en cualquier otro momento de las últimas
décadas.
Prácticamente desde que Richard Nixon puso
en marcha el deshielo político en 1972 las
cosas no iban tan mal entre estos dos países.
Y eso a pesar de que las economías de estos
dos gigantes están mucho más unidas que
en cualquier otro momento histórico.
Fijaos.
(El comercio entre EE.UU. y China alcanzó
un récord en 2022 a pesar de las tensiones.
Nikkei Asia)
Hablamos de un gigantesco volumen comercial
de algo más de 690 mil millones de dólares.
Y, quizás, precisamente por eso, en los últimos
años una pregunta está recibiendo todo el
protagonismo:
Si las relaciones económicas son tan importantes…
¿Se puede sancionar a China?
¿Se puede utilizar la guerra económica para
debilitar al gigante asiático y lograr que
Xi Jinping y su camarilla desistan de una
agenda tan hostil?
Y ojo porque esto es, en cierto modo, exactamente
lo que se está haciendo.
Empezó Donald Trump con su famosa - y muy
mal planteada - Guerra Comercial.
Y ahora la Administración Biden está siguiendo
unos pasos muy parecidos...
Especialmente en lo que respecta a la tecnología.
Fijaos, el 16 de septiembre de 2022, el asesor
de seguridad nacional de Biden, Jake Sullivan
dio un importante discurso en el que cambió
los objetivos estratégicos de Estados Unidos.
De apostar por mantener una cierta “ventaja
relativa” sobre sus rivales - básicamente
China - a querer lograr que esa ventaja “sea
lo más grande posible”.
De esta forma la estrategia de seguridad nacional
de Estados Unidos ya no se limita a querer
liderar, sino que ahora en términos tecnológicos
y respecto a China quiere apabullar, quiere
ir muy por delante cueste lo que cueste.
Y eso es lo que explica noticias como estas:
(7 de octubre de 2022: La Administración
Biden toma medidas drásticas contra el acceso
de China a la tecnología de chips.
La Casa Blanca impuso amplias restricciones
a la venta de semiconductores y equipos de
fabricación de chips a China, en un intento
de frenar el acceso de este país a tecnologías
críticas.
NY Times)
(9 de octubre de 2022: EE.UU. pretende restringir
la inversión tecnológica en China
La administración Biden prepara nuevas normas
que restringirían el flujo de dólares estadounidenses
a China.
NY Times)
Un tipo de medidas que recientemente se han
visto fortalecidas.
Mirad.
(30 de enero de 2023: Japón y los Países
Bajos se suman a las restricciones de EE.UU.
a China.)
Estos son los 3 países que hoy por hoy dominan
la producción de equipos de fabricación
de chips de alta gama.
Así que en cierto modo esto es una sanción.
Estados Unidos está impidiendo la venta a
China de los diseños y la producción de
los microchips más avanzados de microchips
y también de las máquinas que permiten fabricar
esos microchips.
Y esto es importantísimo.
(El principal fabricante de chips nacional
de China, SMIC produce chips que están varías
generaciones por detrás de la vanguardia
del mercado.
SMIC actualmente fabrica microchips de 14
nanómetros y recientemente ha dicho que podría
fabricar pequeñas cantidades de 7.
Para que os hagáis una idea TSMC y Samsung
están fabricando ya ampliamente microchips
de 5 y 3 nanómetros.
Un microchip de 5 nanómetros es aproximadamente
3 veces más rápido o eficiente que uno de
14.)
Y, claro, para que China pueda llegar a ese
nivel necesita las máquinas que permitan
esa producción, por ejemplo las máquinas
de litografía ultravioleta extrema fabricadas
por la empresa holandesa ASML.
La empresa más avanzada del mundo en esta
cuestión.
Pero ahora China ya no podrá comprar ese
tipo de tecnología.
Lo que puede retrasar en una década o más
sus planes.
Estas son “sanciones” que ya están en
marcha…
Pero, la pregunta es, ¿se podría o se debería
ir mucho más allá si por ejemplo Xi Jinping
sigue avanzando en su agenda hostil o, incluso,
toma medidas contra Taiwán?
Realmente, ¿que persigue la Administración
Biden con esta política?
Pues bien, vayamos por partes.
Como podéis ver en pantalla existen varios
tiempos de sanciones.
Pero en lo que aquí respecta las dos más
importantes, las dos que tendrían más sentido
y más impacto serían las sanciones financieras
y los controles a la exportación, como por
ejemplo, los que ya hemos visto.
Respecto a las sanciones financieras Estados
Unidos podría amenazar con congelar los activos
de China, tal y como ha hecho con Rusia.
China tiene algo más de 3 billones de dólares
en reservas en Estados Unidos y otros países
aliados de este.
Sin embargo, esto a medio plazo podría ser
una muy mala idea.
Primero porque reduciría la atracción de
capitales.
Y por otro porque China podría reaccionar
confiscando las inversiones occidentales en
el país.
Hablamos, según los datos del Centro de Estudios
Estratégicos e Internacionales, de unos 3,6
billones de dólares de inversión directa
y 2,2 billones en acciones, bonos y similares.
Luego otro tipo de sanciones financieras sería
cortar la operativa de sus bancos con los
bancos internacionales.
Eso sería algo así como el botón nuclear.
El problema es que eso hundiría el comercio
con China.
Si no se pueden pagar los intercambios de
bienes estos no se van a producir.
Incluso introducir restricciones menores como
la exclusión de SWIFT tendría un impacto
considerable…
para China pero también para los propios
países occidentales que de repente se encontrarían
con una escasez enorme de todo tipo de productos.
Sería un caos total, muchas empresas occidentales
colapsarían y la inflación se iría por
las nubes.
Pensad que China es el mayor exportador del
mundo y produce tantas cosas como Estados
Unidos y Europa juntos.
Así que no, no parece una buena idea.
Y eso nos lleva directamente a las sanciones
comerciales…
A los aranceles y a la restricción de importaciones.
Los aranceles no son muy eficientes y acaban
pagando el pato - y la factura - los consumidores
occidentales.
De hecho, según las estimaciones de la Reserva
Federal de Nueva York los aranceles de Trump
costaron una media de 830 dólares anuales
por hogar.
Así que eso nos deja solo con dos medidas
posibles, dos medidas mucho más graduales
y quirúrgicas.
Reducir progresivamente el peso de China en
las cadenas de producción internacional.
El problema es que esto es un proceso muy
largo.
Así que, sobre todo, la opción pasa por
restringir el acceso del gigante asiático
acceso a determinadas importaciones.
Pero aquí hay que ser muy selectivos, porque
las fábricas de China tienen que seguir produciendo
y, además, habría que evitar a toda costa
el conflicto.
No olvidemos que China es una potencia nuclear
con planes muy claros, fijaos:
(China estudia triplicar su arsenal de cabezas
nucleares hasta 900 en 2035, mientras se prevé
una nueva escalada de las tensiones con Estados
Unidos por Taiwán.
Japan Times)
Así que por ejemplo bloquear su suministro
de petróleo no tendría mucho sentido: frenaría
la producción china, crearía una crisis
mundial y quizás, incluso, un choque mitar.
Por eso hay que ser mucho más selectivos.
¿Es un problema que China sea la fábrica
del mundo?
No, el problema en todo caso sería que fuese
una potencia tecnológica de primer nivel.
¿Y sabéis qué?
En este aspecto China sigue siendo muy dependiente.
Sí, China exporta pero también se traga
una enorme cantidad de productos del extranjero.
Sin ir más lejos, su principal importación
además del petróleo son los microchips y
otros productos tecnológicos avanzados.
¿Y quiénes son sus principales proveedores?
Pues ya os digo que Japón, Corea del Sur,
Estados Unidos, Taiwán, Alemania y algún
otro país occidental dominan la inmensa mayor
parte de las importaciones tecnológicas de
China.
De esta forma, restringir el acceso a la tecnología
de vanguardia podría ser un golpe muy duro
para las ambiciones de Xi Jinping sin que
se pusiera en riesgo el papel actual de China
en la economía mundial.
No tener acceso a la tecnología de vanguardia
podría, sin ir más lejos, limitar la capacidad
militar de este país.
Y sí, eso es exactamente lo que explica la
estrategia de la Administración Biden y las
restricciones tecnológicas.
¿Te habías parado a pensarlo?
Pero…
Sintetizando: ¿Se puede sancionar a China?
Con carácter general lo cierto es que no.
El remedio podría llegar a ser peor que la
enfermedad.
El caos sería generalizado.
El papel de China en la economía mundial
se ha vuelto demasiado importante.
Ahora bien, lo que sí se puede hacer es ralentizar
su desarrollo impidiendo su acceso a tecnologías
y productos de vanguardia.
Además esto haría que muchas empresas trasladaran
poco a poco sus cadenas de producción fuera
de China…
Que a largo plazo puede ser la mejor opción
para no depender de los caprichos de Xi Jinping
o dictadores parecidos.
Que existan alternativas.
Claro que el problema es que esto requiere
tomar medidas cuanto antes y no esperar a
un posible choque, porque en un plazo de tiempo
corto estas medidas no serían efectivas.
Por supuesto, Estados Unidos y sus aliados
tendrían que pisar el acelerador para acelerar
su desarr ollo tecnológico.
Esto probablemente requiera de nuevos incentivos
a las empresas y la inversión; una política
activa del gobierno y una puerta mucho más
abierta para la atracción de talento internacional.
Y sí, China podría intentar ponerse a la
par…
Pero sigue estando muy por detrás, sufre
una enorme fuga de talentos y el peso de las
grandes empresas públicas - que son mucho
menos innovadora s que las privadas - está
volviendo a crecer.
Es decir, que esta estrategía realmente podría
llegar a funcionar.
E, incluso, si no disuade al gobierno chino
de su agenda al menos podría limitar su capacidad
de maniobra.
Esto al menos es lo que parecen pensar en
Washington y lo que explica los últimos movimientos
de Estados Unidos.
Pero llegados hasta aquí la pregunta es para
ti:
¿Crees que esta es una buena estrategia?
¿Crees que hay que restringir aún más el
acceso de China a la tecnología occidental?
¿Sería una respuesta suficiente para Xi
Jinping?
¿Qué podría hacer el gobierno chino?
Déjanos en los comentarios tus impresiones
y abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.